[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
النهارده هتكلم عن مشروع عملته
[موسيقى]
قبل ما نكمل المشروع ده اصلا عموما اسمه
سوفت وير علاقته بالعلاج الطبيعي انا يعني
لو في ناس كتير عندنا يعني تلاحظوا وفي
ناس دخلت داخلين سنه اولى عليك بيقولوا
يعني انا كان نفسي ادخل طبي
اعمل حاجه عاليه شويه بعد كده متعود مع
الكليه وبيحبها بعد كده انا برضه كنت كده
يعني بس انا مكنتش لازم
تكنولوجيا اصلا
انا اللي يعرفني من زمان انا من وانا صغير
وانا ماسك كمبيوتر يعني ممكن تقول ان انا
بدات اول كورس في حياتي كان سنه ثالثه
ابتدائي اول كود كنت بعمل على خفيف كده
فالموضوع يعني بالنسبه لحقه كان الموضوع
حلو جدا
وفعلا بيحبه وهيستمتع جدا
قعدت بعد كده بعد ما ادوني حتى في البيت
لما لقوني بحب الكمبيوتر دين اول كورسات
دي بقيت اطور نفسي كل شويه لدرجه لقيت حد
من قرايبي يعني مش عارف تقريبا انا عيلتي
ده التكنولوجيا كان عمل لعبه هو واصدقائه
وباحه ومن ساعتها الموضوع جه في دماغ وقلت
لا انا لازم اعمل لعبه برضو قعدت فتره
برضو في الانجليزي ما كنتش احسن حاجه دورت
على كتب مسكت كتب دي كنت بتفرج على الصور
واطبقها عملت اول لعبه فعلا كنت في قمه
الموضوع تطور معي بعد كده فده تطور اكتر
وبالمناسبه
تطوير الالعاب ده داخل في حاجات كثيره جدا
وعشان تعمله لازم تكون عارف حاجات كتيره
جدا منها ان انت تعرف في الكود ايه تعرف
ازاي تحكي قصه تعرف ازاي تخلي الواحد يشعر
اللعبه او الفيل اللي انت بتقدمه فالموضوع
اداني خبرات كثير وبرضه في سن صغير
فالموضوع كان بالنسبه له حلو جدا
قعدت بعد كده يعني لحد قدمت في مسابقه
اسمها ابداع
كانت لسه داخل سنه اولى دخلت ابتكارات
علميه المسابقه دي كانت بتتكلم عن
كل واحد بيقدم والبرمجه ومش طبيعي موجود
في المسابقه كلهم الهندسه
وكمان اتاهلت للنهايه بس الواحد
كملت بعد كده حصلت ظروف ساعه كورونا
والدنيا دي عندي كل الاجهزه تقريبا اللي
كنت بشتغل عليها برامج اللاب بتاعي باظ
والكمبيوتر باظ وحل مجال زي الجلد او
البرمجه اللي هو ليه الالعاب حاجات تقيله
برضو كان عايز حاجه تقيله يعني جهاز تقيل
امكانيات عاليه شويه عشان اقدر اجرب حاجات
اعلى
شويه وبعد كده بدات اتجه قلت حاجه جديده
اتعلمت لغه اسمها
واظن في ناس كتيره تعرف على البايثون دي
عشان هي لغه مشهوره
كواحد بيتعلم لغه برمجه
ممكن
الموضوع كان بالنسبه لي سهل بدات على
الموضوع اتعلمت بايسون بعد ما دخلت اكتشفت
التكنولوجيا جديده اسمها ايه اسمها ايه
الكمبيوتر عباره عن تكنولوجيا بتحول
التصوير الرقمي التصوير بتاع الكاميرا
العادي لارقام وده اقدر
استخدمه في كذا حاجه في المجال الطبي اصلا
يعني شفت ان هي بتستخدم في اشاعات تستخدم
في
الحاجات اللي ليها دعوه
بالاي بالذات ولقيت ان في ناس بتستخدمها
بره كمان في الكاميرات لحاجه وكده قعدت
برده اطور نفسي فيها لحد لما دخلت في
ساعتها في كورس الكمبيوتر ده بيعمل
بتاعه الجسم
تعلم في الموضوع هنا جت الفكره لا بتكلم
عليها المفروض اسمها اتش
انا كنا واخدين بالنا احنا كنا اصلا
باديين ان احنا في حاجه من الجهه
ده المفروض يكون بيعملوا عيان صح فايه
الادمان من العيان ده بيعملوا صح كات هنا
المشكله انه لو عمله غلط انا مش هعرف هو
قاعد في بيته مش هيكون محدش فده ممكن
يعمله بعد كده ممكن ما يتحسنش ليه ممكن
يكون اصلا بيعمل
التمرين فاله
[موسيقى]
دف
الانجل دي
ونعمل سوفت وير يعمل يعمل
كمان التدريبات عليه
فبدالنا نطور فيه تاني يعني هو ده التعريف
بتاعه اللي عمل
بيعمل
بيساعد وبيساعد برده ايه البيشن بحيث احنا
حاليا شغالين ان احنا بعد
للعيان ويخلص بيبعت داتا بقى زي بريف
التمرين بتاعه هو اتدرب قد ايه عمل كاميرا
ويكمل وابعته عن طريق الكمبيوتر
ده
اصلا معموله من 1590
بيستخدموها ناس كتير اصلا عشان كده هي لغه
سهله في التعامل اصلا
[موسيقى]
مشروع اصلا
بعيد ان انا بعمل
يعني مجموعه فيديوهات
واحد بس بيعمل تمرين
معين فلما واحد مره من قدام اولا هعلمها
قبل كده اعمل له مش بي يحفظها جوه وفي
الاسترش بتاعته ويعرفك ان انت عامل
الموضوع ده صح ولا غلط
ده مثال على الكمبيوتر يعني انا مثلا لو
حطيت الصوره دي ومعرفه قبل كده بكذا صوره
رونالدو المفروض هيبين ان هو رونالدو عايز
اخلي الصوره ابيض واسود
تمام
[موسيقى]
هي دي
ده مثال للحاجات اللي ظهرت اسمها
[تصفيق]
فيميشن
ده عشان هو اقدر
تمام
ده جزء من البرنامج هو بيعمل الفيديو اصلا
متسهل يعني ممكن يعني ممكن يتسجل
ما بينهم لان انا ببين قدامكم ازاي حسب
بتاعه
هنا لما بكون عامل قبل كده في خطوط
الخطوط دي والنقط دي بتتحط في حاجه اسمها
كل دايره لها طيب قيمه اكس واي وعن طريق
الاكس والواي دول بعمل معادلات عن طريق
وبسمله بحسب الانجل بتاعنا الانجل دي هي
دي صوره من البرنامج حاليا انا صورت ساكن
بس هي ده شكل البرنامج بيقيس هنا بيشوف
بتاعه الارمه هل هي ولا ده وبيعمل كام
كونت انا عملتها ولو انا عايز
بعد كده
هو الموضوع ممكن يكون بسيط ممكن تلاقوه
بالاول بس يعني كان فيه يعني داخلين حتى
لف سبع شهور شغالين فيه الموضوع بيتطور
اكتر شاركني حتى الان في البرنامج ده في
كذا
مسابقه ابداع السنه دي شاركنا في مسابقه
اسمها تكني صدفه المنيا ورحنا تكني سمك في
القاهره
وكمان يعني ان شاء الله في مسابقه جايه في
الطريق فيعني ادعوا لنا
هدفي من كل ده ان الواحد طالما انت حاجه
يعني كان فيه حد يعرف ستانلي اللي هو عامل
ملف معظم شخصيات مارفل سبايدر مان الناس
دي كان يقول لو في فكره في دماغك ومقتنع
بيها وحاسس ان هي صح ما تسيبهاش غير لما
تكون حاسس ان انت رضيت وخلصتها
انا ناس دخل البرنامج في العلاج الطبيعي
انت ايه اللي جابك علاج طبيعي اصلا هو
الموضوع انا كدكتور علاج طبيعي الموضوع
فني جدا انا ما كنتش للفكره دي انا عندي
المعلومات اللي عندي في العلاج الطبيعي
[تصفيق]